Pharmacy was an early target for health information technology.
In fact, I worked on one of
the first ambulatory pharmacy systems in the early to mid 1970s.
As a result, codes for medications were also an early development.
As the use of commercial pharmacy software grew,
companies created proprietary coding systems for the many aspects of medication
including clinical issues such as
drug drug interactions not covered by the simple NDC product codes.
Starting in 2001, the National Library of Medicine
created RxNorm to reconcile these commercial codes.
Each medication has a unique RxNorm RXCUI number
of up to eight digits that can be used to retrieve a great deal of information.
You will find references to RxNorm in fire resources.